[Music]
one beard is gone
nearly 50 years after Star Trek a
William Shatner is boldly going where he
has never gone before it's all for the
travel adventure show better late than
never which airs tonight on NBC and the
86 year old TV icon stopped by 80 to
share with me his secret to keeping a
life and hyperdrive Wow look at this
okay you do not slow down at all because
you're doing some kind of new project or
activity every time I see you well I am
I'm doing I'm doing all kinds of new
things George this is the biggest cuckoo
clock
William joins George Foreman Terry
Bradshaw Henry Winkler and comedian Jeff
die to trot all over the globe it was a
strange premise five guys go off and you
fill them four days at a time and do
they get on or do the are they amusing
and do they have adventures and and does
it connect with the audience and all
those questions were answered
there's Terry Bradshaw with four rings
Super Bowl rings figure a fan of them oh
my god George Foreman to time every way
champion knocks me out of the ring and
the first season traveling the world on
NBC's dime was a big draw for Shatner it
was a beautiful beautiful time we all
went had a great time saw things we
would never have seen with the ease of
somebody else handling everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
trustworthy out of you all that would
leave my wallet with anybody but George
Foreman he's like Buddha
he's like a silent wise man who's very
funny yes you still didn't cross the
finish line oh I knew was something
wrong
I know retire is not in your vocabulary
no retire to me is putting another piece
of rubber on the car he had good answer
I think that's the best answer that I
have ever heard that's always so much
fun to have William stopped by and put a
fun show in fact I asked William if the
guys really liked each other as much as
it seems like they do on the show and he
told me yes in fact he has Terry
Bradshaw come over to his house to watch
football
[Music]
you
[Music]